Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today, we are going to look at an incredible new
paper, where we are going to simulate flows around
thin shells, rods, the wind blowing at leaves,
airflow through a city, and get this, we will
produce spiral vortices around an aircraft,
and even perform some wind tunnel simulations.
Now, many of our previous
videos are about real time
fluid simulation methods that
are often used in computer games,
and others that run for a long time and are
typically used in feature-length movies.
But not this, this work is not for that. This new
paper can simulate difficult coupling effects,
which means that it can deal with the movement
of air currents around this thin shell.
We can also take a hair brush without
bristles, and have an interesting simulation.
Or even better, add tiny tiny
bristles to its geometry,
and see how much more of a turbulent flow this
creates. I already love this paper. So good.
Now, onwards to more serious applications.
So why simulate thin shells? What is
all this useful for? Well, of course, simulating
wind turbines. That is an excellent application,
we are getting there. Hmm…talking about thin
shells…what else? Of course, aircraft! Now hold
on to your papers and marvel at these beautiful
spiral vortices that this simulator can create.
So, is this all for show, or is
this what would really happen
in reality? We will take a
closer look at that in a moment.
With that, yes, the authors claim that this
is much more accurate than previous methods in
its class. Well then, let’s give it a devilishly
difficult test, a real aerodynamic simulation in
a wind tunnel. In these cases, getting really
accurate results is critical. For instance,
here we would like to see that if we were to add
a spoiler to this car, how much of an aerodynamic
advantage we would get in return. Here are
the results from the real wind tunnel test,
and now, hold on to your papers and let’s see
how the new method compares. Wow. Goodness! It
is not perfect by any means, but seems accurate
enough that we can see the wake flow of the car
clearly enough so that we can make a decision
on that spoiler. You know what, let’s keep it.
So we compared the simulation against
reality. Now, let’s compare a simulation
against another simulation. So, against a previous
method. Yes, the new one is significantly more
accurate than its predecessor. Why? Because the
previous one introduces significant boundary layer
separations at the top of the car. The new one
says that this is what will happen in reality, so
how do we know? Of course, we check. Yes,
that is indeed right. Absolutely amazing.
And note that this work appeared just about
a year ago. So much improvement in so little
time. The pace of progress in computer
graphics research is out of this world!
Okay, so it is accurate. Really accurate. But, we
already have accurate algorithms, so how fast is
it? Well, the proper aerodynamic simulations take
from days to weeks to compute, but this airplane
simulation took only minutes. How many minutes?
60 minutes to be exact. Wow. And within these 60
minutes, the same spiral vortices show up as
the ones in real wind tunnel tests. So good!
But really, how can this be so fast? How is this
even possible? The key to doing all this faster
is that the new proposed method is massively
parallel. This means that it can slice up
one big computing task into many small ones
that can be taken care of independently. And,
as a result, it takes advantage of our graphics
cards and can squeeze every drop of performance
out of it. That is very challenging
for an algorithm of this complexity.
So, where does this put us? Of course, the final
simulation should still be done with the old tools
just to make sure. However, this new method will
be able to help engineers quickly iterate on early
ideas, and only commit to week-long simulations
when absolutely necessary. So, we can go from
idea to conclusions in a matter of an hour, not
in a matter of a week. This will be an amazing
time saver so the engineers can try more designs.
Testing more ideas leads to more knowledge. That
leads to better vehicles, better wind turbines.
Loving it. And all this improvement in just
a year. If I didn’t see this with my own eyes, I
could not believe this. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!